foreign
to Florida and talk to the great and
wonderful Amy what's up Amy
hello Dr John well thank you for taking
my call thanks for calling hi
um I I feel kind of silly with this but
I want to thank you for taking my call
um my question you listen to the show
ever
I I have and I feel like my story is not
as dramatic as most of the ones you deal
with so I was surprised that Jenna
called me actually no we have to be
careful the show doesn't turn into Jerry
Springer so it's good just to have some
human some human stuff what's up yeah
this is human stuff um my question is
how do I cope with the anger and the
grief that I feel by being blindsided by
my own life
um that's what it okay well before I
start I just want to say there's no
ifsens or buts I love my kids with all
my heart
[Laughter]
I know people are going to be listening
and they're going to be like oh my gosh
she's not thankful this is one of my
favorite ways people start now listen
okay he's great but okay
I love my kids I can't wait to hear what
happens okay okay
so my husband and I have been married um
21 years me too congratulations I know
how hard thank you personally that's a
long time congrats it is a long time and
it has been very hard but um we had two
kids
um in our early 20s
all the kids we were had planned to have
we thought you know we'll have our
family we'll have our kids and you know
buy our mid to late 40s we'll be empty
nesting are you pregnant
no no okay oh God I'm not all right I
thought you were pregnant um
so
um just as we were kind of leaving the
little kid fog you know where you never
see each other you you are just mad at
each other all the time uh the kids take
up everything
um we found out in our early 30s that we
were pregnant again
um so we had another kid
um kind of rolled with the punches there
and we're like okay well that just kind
of pushes things a little bit and uh
2020 rolled around and I remember
posting on Facebook how excited I was
because I was just feeling like I was
finally starting to feel me again
um I feel like myself you know I've been
a stay-at-home mom this whole time and
you just kind of get lost in it you feel
invisible you feel
like you don't exist and that you just
aren't even a real person anymore and um
I know that that lasts while the kids
are small and as they get older it kind
of goes away but anyway
2020 came I was about to turn 40 I
posted that on Facebook and a month
later I found out I was pregnant again
at 40. and um from that moment I lost it
I immediately fell into like a deep
grief like grieving what I thought my
40s were going to look like
okay I'm trying not to cry I'll cry away
dude
um listen you're right you're right
I I feel angry a lot that I had to start
over at 40. I feel angry that as my
older kids are transitioning that I
don't get to transition with them I feel
like I've been stuck at the starting
line for nearly 20 years and my friends
are all starting to empty nests and
going on trips with their husbands and
finally starting to live again
and I haven't been out to my dinner with
my husband in months we don't see each
other we have no time together we've
been living in a little kid fog for 20
years and
I'm just grieving so hard that I'm I'm
43 and it feels like I'm gonna be
invisible for another 20 years and I I
won't get to live until I'm 60 and I'm
just so
spent time emotionally like spent I'm
physically touched out I look in the
mirror and the person I see just keeps
getting older and I feel like my life
has just been stuck in the same season
for so long and I love my children with
all my heart but I don't love my life
and it fills me with guilt every morning
and grief and anger and I know it sounds
selfish but it feels like I don't exist
I feel like I have so much potential I
will never get to see the light of day
and I guess
I'm calling in just to sing say how do
you have any advice how to cope with
this yeah yeah
well one thank you for saying all that
out loud yeah
yeah it helps have you ever said it all
out loud like that
oh yeah
okay hey I'm proud of you okay
bombs what we do here that's that's my
job that's my job
um
I don't think for one second that you
don't like your kids
not for a second okay so I want to take
that completely off the table and
anybody you're Hey listen do not read
the YouTube comments because there's
there's gonna be morons that are posting
like oh my gosh I know don't read them
okay I know you promise yeah I promise I
know people that don't have kids are
going to be upset people who think I
don't appreciate them I do I love them
okay number two
getting pregnant with number four at 40
something
absolutely
is right to grieve what you thought was
about to be a whole new Tran a chapter
of your life
yeah 100 you had a picture painted
and it went away instantly
and you were faced with that I call it
like the the guilt shame teeter-totter
of
I don't want this oh great mom great mom
and then it smashes the other side and
you're like oh what a loser and then
it's like oh so yeah you got to get off
the teeter-totter number one okay
um yeah so you're right you are right
and here's what I really want to
challenge you on though can I push back
on the whole I the whole model you've
created
yes please
you have fallen prey to one of the our
culture's most Insidious traps and lies
is what I would say
okay okay here's what it is
that there is some magical Finish Line
somewhere
it doesn't exist
yeah
and what that means is
right now is the life you are choosing
there are billions of people in the
world that don't have don't get choice
right I get that
me
most of the people that's in the show do
and when I say Choice it doesn't mean
like uh it's not like you're suddenly
gonna get a million dollars or suddenly
rent's gonna get cheaper it's not okay
when I say choice I mean
you keep waiting until this season X is
over so then you can start living your
life
and what your body is reacting to right
now is you are choosing consciously to
not live your life
there is a fog no question about it
and then there's a whole whole bunch of
choices
there is chaos with three kids
now a fourth and an infant are you
kidding me and there's a ton of choices
so I'm gonna challenge you because I
love you is that cool
yeah you and your husband have chosen to
not go on dates for months
you'll have chosen to have your sex life
just go away
you'll have chosen to take different
paths
and I have little kid I get how insane
it might sound
but my promise is this
if all of your kids were checking out
and you booked that first vacation and
you showed up at that first vacation
place
the worst part about that is you would
have gone with you
the person who felt like put her life on
hold for 20 something years
and I bet you didn't put it on hold as
much as you think you did
Maybe I'm Wrong
but I bet your kids love their mama
don't they
do and are your kids good kids the good
human beings
they treat people right
I think so
does your husband bathe with some
regularity
well that's questionable question
please don't fall into the Trap that the
only contribution a person can make is
some sort of dollar amount in in a 401k
yeah yeah I know I just I I you've
created
and sustained
yeah I guess it's just um
I
I feel like my brain is wasted uh you
know like I on what I'm not making
reports in some law office
oh no I I don't think I would ever do
that but just what did your brain just
get wasted on
sitting down and playing Barbie dolls
and
just imagine
just my stuff that I've done it day in
and day out
20 years already and I just you've
created a neuronal uh you've created
yeah it's not even a word you've created
um
I'm trying to think of a non-nerd way to
say it
it's okay you can be a nerd I like that
kind of stuff
you've created brain maps for your kids
yeah
you've created their wiring
you've created their nervous system with
them co-created it with them
yeah you could build a residence hall at
a college or you could as an architect
or you can
I don't know
build a small company
or you can build a human
yeah and they're all at various stages
mind-numbingly boring
insanely boring insanely frustrating
insanely rewarding
yeah but there's another story here
underneath this role you found yourself
in
is a woman who for whatever reason does
not like saying out loud what you need
and there's a woman who doesn't like
saying out loud you know what I really
want and fill in the blank
that's the part that I think has gone to
waste
is your voice
yeah
where did she go
you think she's been gone for a long
time I think you're right
yeah because it's always been
everybody else in the houses
is more important all of their needs are
more important
and I would tell you that's a curse of
modern parenting
because if if Mom's not well
you've got nothing to give if your
picture's not full you've got nothing to
pour into your kid's picture
and that's how I feel right now it is
especially thinking about yeah
understand
but the the solution to being spent is
not a season of doing nothing
it's not a season of comparative
analysis watching your friends because I
promise you this I promise you
you're gonna have friends that go on a
couple of their vacations they're like
oh my gosh
and then they're gonna come over to your
house and your daughter's gonna crawl up
into your lap
right before she goes to bed and one of
them is gonna have a tear out on their
face and the other guy's gonna be tough
and he's gonna go man I wish that I
missed that
okay everybody's wondering what it's
like on the other side of the fence
yeah the key to being well is being okay
with what side of the fence you happen
to be on and there is no going back
you're there you have a fourth kid how
old's your kid three oh yes I know three
yeah I I have four and
I can't change it I know that I think
I'm just trying to figure out how to how
to be okay with this I I don't I don't
want you to just be okay with it
yeah that's the thing I don't want to
just survive I want to thrive yes for a
long time so make the choice that Mom
goes first for a season will husband
allow a a wife with a voice
I hope so would he love no that's not a
good answer would he love a wife that
says here's what I need
I'm gonna try I don't know that he's
ever known me as that you know he's
always kind of been like the pants in
the family
so um I'm gonna speak up most men hold
on it's not just a matter of I'm just
gonna speak up because here's what's
gonna happen you're gonna not speak up
and you're gonna explode on him and he's
gonna not know what hit him
yeah
most guys are so desperate to know why
their wife doesn't like them
oh I love him and I do I know you do
but he can see his wife is miserable
yeah and if he's any husband worth a
crap he's wondering what it is about him
that's making that happen
yeah and that's a very selfish way to go
through the world we all do it right men
and women everybody goes to the world
going what about me what about me
but if you sat down and said over the
last 20 years I lost myself in my role
as a wife I lost myself in a role as a
mom and I put every single need in this
home before mine and I've just looked up
and I got nothing left in the tank
yeah
I want to figure out what I even need
I want to figure out what I even want
and I'm going to need you to help around
the house I'm gonna need you to help
with dinner I'm gonna need you to help
with like marriage Retreats who do we
want to become
because we're choosing not to sleep
together we're choosing to sleep in
separate rooms we're choosing all these
choices we're choosing to not go on
dates all these things are choices
and usually these conversations get
really hard
okay it won't be easy and stuff from the
past comes up new surprises will show up
all that
but this is a matter of you deciding
my voice matters in this house
I'm not just hired help
to let give my husband the life he wants
and to raise four kids
I have I'm a co-creator of this place
right
and if you hear nothing else today your
voice matters not only does it matter
it's really really important
that your kids get a vision
what a mom who takes care of herself
looks like
of a mom who says out loud I need this
and dude as a husband I'm so grateful
when my wife says hey I really need
today off even when I'm so frustrated by
it because I needed today off too
yeah we got back from a long vacation
recently and my wife said hey uh
I need
um me and my her two couple of her
girlfriends they're going out they do
this regularly we're going out all day
we're just we're just gonna figure out
where we're gonna go when we go
just wanted I'd been on vacation for two
weeks with my kids I just needed like my
brain Clear
dude I was so grateful that she said
what she needed out loud and she went
and they had a great time and I had a
blast with my kids I said to just change
the focus of the day
and actually thank goodness because we
had we had such a blast I mean me and my
little ones
I'd say that to tell you this
it's not just about speaking up it's
about taking your husband out and saying
the way we've chosen to do marriage up
until now
doesn't work anymore
I want to hear from you what kind of
marriage do you want to have I'm going
to speak up here's the kind of marriage
I want to have here's the kind of life I
want to have
here's the kind of kids and we're gonna
get babysitters because we're going out
and we're gonna go on vacation
and we're gonna drag the kid along
it's gonna be fine we have a blast
kid can do what we can do they'll be
great or one of these older kids that
we've raised for 20 years can come back
and babysit whatever we'll figure that
out
but we're going to live the life we're
going to live and the kids are going to
be a part of that not the other way
around
the modern American house that revolves
around children is insane
the home should revolve around mom the
Revolt home should revolve around Dad
should we revolve around parents
not the other way around
I'm gonna send you a copy of my new book
building a non-anxious life I want you
guys to go through that book together
you and your husband I'll send it to you
for free I want you to do the exercises
it's about building a life that is
different now
life where everybody speaks up
everyone's hurt everyone decides what
we're gonna do everyone works together
and most importantly
the house where we have peace
and you're outside in that beast in a
long time that's because Mom has taken
my like Amy is taking Amy and just
shoved her down it's time for the world
to meet Amy for the first time
and that starts at your at your dinner
table
call anytime Amy will be with you every
step of the way this will get harder
before it gets easier okay
so get tough but you're worth it so are
those little ones man